just finished the book that was written
by a republican California state Senator
H.L Richardson it's called
confrontational politics
you know right now it is less Patrick
about Republican and Democrat it's less
about political parties it is more about
philosophies of governess the United
States of America was founded on a very
incredible
revolutionary premise that the
individual is supreme and Sovereign over
the institution of government now we
have people that believe that the
institution of government being at the
federal state local levels are Supreme
and Sovereign over the individual that
they make decisions based upon that
they're more so concerned about how do
we make the individual wedded to us how
do we make the individual dependent upon
us and you can look at the policies that
come forward we have got to get uh to
the point where we go back and talk
about individual rights freedoms
Liberties uh and we have been lacking in